superheroes  cannot be allowed to exist  [Music]  i have no intention to leave my work  [Music]  unfinished  [ __ ] i have a plan  [Music]  great  [Music]  where do we start  i would like to thank ridge wallets for  sponsoring this video  these wallets are light sleek compact  and  designed to easily fit in your front  pocket  unlike the traditional wallets which is  large and bulky  the ridge wallet can hold up to 12 cards  plus has room for cash  there's over 30 colors and styles  including carbon fiber  and burnt titanium so get 10 off today  with free worldwide shipping and returns  by going to rich.com  terror or using a link in the  description and guys don't forget to  enter code tara to get your discount  thanks for watching